[Music]
my name is james lake and i am a
cardboard artist
i would describe my work as a cardboard
sculpture in its purest sense
i've been working with cardboard
probably about 20 to 25 years i very
much like taking recycled materials and
building them into significant pieces of
art that people will hopefully be
touched by
in an emotional way
[Music]
so getting down to the the nitty-gritty
of the sculpting process so we start
with kind of a flat kind of design or
shape
[Music]
and then that shape is then turned into
a mask by adding extra pieces of card
one of the beauties of kind of working
with card in small pieces is i can
actually take something that will become
part of a larger sculpture and i can
actually hold it in my hands so you can
actually see
the different angles that you need to
kind of work on
once i've got these kind of angles that
gives me a
a sense of the overall shape and
proportion i then start using pieces of
card that could become cladding as it
were like like you'd get
on the outside of a house
[Music]
in the human body you don't get right
angles
so essentially what i'm doing is working
out ways to kind of curve and kind of
bend the card or press the corrugations
together to actually mold round the form
and then once i've got an overall kind
of shape then i actually return to the
surface details now say for instance all
the features like the eyes nose and
mouth
all kind of have this kind of curved
aspect to them so you are kind of
thinking about what is the right shape
from the front so it might be a drawn
nose or mouth and then you kind of
thinking about well actually what
happens when you curve that car does the
shape kind of get smaller
i find kind of with the figurative
sculpture that what finishes the work is
actually the hair
now when you think about hair and you
think well actually how would you
replicate that in cardboard essentially
you have to think about each area of
hair as its own separate kind of entity
or section it's a bit like a a very
complicated jigsaw as it were
and i don't always know quite where it's
going to go
okay so
this sculpture is going to be called
youth it's about two three weeks old so
it's kind of fairly new in its
conception
this sculpture was quite a complex and
and tricky thing to do because it's
actually in the process of jumping the
work is off the floor i think by about
15 to 20 centimeters it's held in place
by a steel bar that kind of runs through
the downward leg so it needs to be
fairly lightweight
with that in mind what i've done is i've
used
a variety
of lightweight cardboard so i've kind of
been using some of this cardboard
it's a honeycomb cardboard and it has
kind of a strength to it but you can
also press the wear and kind of mold it
and kind of push into position so i've
kind of done that in a number of
different places around the world
the different types of cardboard that i
use in my work first i use a single
corrugated card now this is kind of the
type of card that you get in most kind
of packaging that you'll get delivered
for your door and it's kind of very easy
to bend and curve
now this this card is just like a
corrugated row it sometimes comes in
packaging inside the kind of boxes but
you can also buy it from different
suppliers or they kind of use it a lot
in schools it's good for quick kind of
covers in between kind of structures
this is a slightly more specialist kind
of cardboard but i actually get this
from a recycling
community resource center here in exeter
it has this really nice corrugated
filling which is great for strength and
it's incredibly lightweight but it also
functions
uh well inside calvin armstrong another
type of cardboard that i use is this
double corrugated card now this is great
in terms of it's kind of more load
bearing so you can actually put weight
and pressure on this and this is really
good for kind of building legs and arms
and if you have a sculpture that's kind
of standing you want it to to be strong
and upright and not to kind of move too
much and finally this card
comes in the
packaging that you might find in the
supermarket for soft drinks and things
like that so it's really good it's
actually really good to kind of paint on
and that's kind of about it with regards
to the materials that i use
now apart from the honeycomb cardboard
i've been mostly using a single
corrugated card because that's kind of
quite lightweight and you can see the
masking tape as well where i've kind of
held it together
okay so nothing in this sculpture is
kind of set in stone by any means but
what i'll do is i'll kind of think about
ways that i could start putting in
that the structure and the the detail
and the pattern from kind of pieces of
card like this
so i've got a a very strong kind of pair
of scissors that's really really
important now these scissors are kitchen
scissors i think they're normally used
for cutting things like meat or or
things like that so when it comes to
cutting um
single corrugated card
scissors work fine
[Music]
the tools of mayan trade are very very
simple and kind of paired down i use
cardboard
masking tape hot melt glue gun i use
scissors
i use a craft knife i very much like the
idea that when you're working with card
it's brilliant to have a restricted
palette of colors as it were because you
don't have a sophisticated set of
materials you have to be really
creative with with the marks that you
make
so
i've cut a piece
and then what i'll do is i've kind of
work out where it's gonna naturally fit
and what i've done is i've kind of
overlapped the segments and the strips
so that i'm containing space inside this
sculpture just because i want to reduce
the overall weight so this is kind of a
good way to do it so it's a criss-cross
kind of lattice kind of affair with the
work
so i'll just kind of adjust the shapes
that i'm using so i'm kind of happy with
the piece
and then
obviously kind of run a bead of glue
down
now a particular challenge with this
piece of work is that the glue itself
has an inherent weight and with
something that is so finely and kind of
delicately balanced i have to allow for
the weight of the glue in this process
so with poses like this i tend to not
use kind of too much in the way of glue
so i try and kind of be
as sparing as it can be
the final stage for my work is actually
looking at how it might operate in its
various dimensions because sometimes
there are bits that kind of get missed
especially if i'm say sat in one
position or say sat on the floor and i
don't realize what somebody might view
as a spectator from a different angle so
you can imagine
making a piece of sculpture in a small
space
it's quite tricky you can also imagine
making a piece of art on one leg is
quite tricky but when you combine the
two you realize that can be
kind of a bit challenging
perfect
so in terms of kind of sealing the work
i've used a ceiling called pavapol which
is normally used as a fabric stiffener
but it works as a a waterproof agent
because there's nothing worse than say
spending a long time making something
out of cardboard and then somebody comes
along with chocolate on their fingers
and they kind of touch the work and then
you know it's quite hard to repair so
the waterproofing agent that i use acts
as an extra layer on the card and to
some degree kind of stiffens the outside
of the cardboard so it makes it kind of
more resistant to damage
i think what i'd like to tell people
working with this process is that there
was an awful lot in the way of trial and
error
so it's very different to say carving in
stone where you know if you might make a
mistake and i i make so many mistakes
with my word that you would not believe
and it's in those kind of imperfections
that you kind of find the the
personality and the the various kind of
aspects that make the work individual
yeah i'm getting there so yeah
i think kind of
my most favorite part of the building
process probably happens somewhere kind
of in the middle
because i know
roughly at this stage what i'm going to
be making and i also know that i've got
something solid in front of me that i
can relate to
and at that point it's normally
where the interesting inspirational or
unintentional aspect to the work kind of
emerges i think sometimes that the most
complicated part the process for me
is
realizing the technical challenges of
kind of building something on scale
my passion for making things out of
cardboard is something that i've kind of
sustained for a long time i i wouldn't
know how to make it from any other
material and i think i shouldn't need to
really
i've always hoped with my work that
people will see that you can make art
from any material so if anything i i
would like to kind of think like i can
inspire as many people as possible to be
able to make artwork
i hope with the cardboard that
it makes people believe that anything is
possible
you